c'est un joyau du patrimoine un bâtiment
classé du xviiie siècle qui pourrait
devenir propriété privée fin août un
investisseur a fait une proposition
d'achat des hospices saint pierre depuis
les habitants ne décolère pas j'ai eu
l'impression qu'on me volait même si je
ne suis pas réel propriétaire dans
l'esprit arnhem appartient comme à tous
les arnétois alors pour tenter de sauver
ces lieux une pétition a été mise en
place
neuf cents personnes y ont déjà apposé
leur signature
je voulais sa petite case pour pour
signer la pétition pour garder ce
bâtiment merveilleux voilà le sait une
sans hésiter à l'intérieur des hospices
le musée des arts de la table une
association gérée par trois salariés qui
se retrouvent aujourd'hui dans le flou
le plus total
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des salariés
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de la maison
régionale parce qu'on parle des hospices
mais l'association c'est l'association
de la maison régionale où est ce qu'on
va aller on va dire que c'est sa mort la
rénovation de ce site exceptionnel
s'élèverait à 800 milles euros une somme
impossible à débourser pour l'amérique
le patrimoine c'est très bien mais il ce
patrimoine là bas il faut l'entretenir
il ya des coups et des courriels seuil
est bon ces coups là qu'est ce qui va
les chiffres us qui va les entraîner
chez les lézards nettoyant toits de la
ville d'ernée alors pour renflouer les
caisses la commune n'hésitent plus à
vendre des bâtiments historiques
elle a déjà trouvé preneur pour le
château des princes de condé et l'ancien
hôtel de la perception
hier soir le conseil municipal s'est
réuni pour discuter de la vente des
hospices un débat houleux en présence de
l'acheteur que nous n'avons pas pu
filmer les élus ont décidé de reporter
leur décision à la prochaine réunion du
conseil